avril it's so good to see you how you
doing
i'm doing good
how are you i'm fantastic uh love sucks
uh let's start here where was your head
at and where was your heart at going
into this
um i mean that's just how i was feeling
when i started the album i had like
gotten out of i've gone through like a
rough breakup and like i i was just
feeling like
um kind of like exhausted on love and
like i needed like a break from it i was
just like this is no fun anymore like i
need a hot minute and so i wrote the
song called love socks and i went in the
studio and i told the guys that i was
working with him like this is where i'm
at in my life right now
and
that was like one of the first songs
that we worked on and it set the tone
for the rest of the album in saying that
though like
obviously
kind of like looking at my life and my
ups and downs in love which love it
let's just face it love's not easy it's
a lot of work it's hard you know it it
can hurt you know it has its ups and
downs so i cut in a very playful
way with a sense of humor i kind of
wrote an album about that
right because i'm looking i'm just gonna
like on the on the surface i'm just
gonna say on the surface okay
um boys lie bite me love it when you
hate me love sucks avalanche f you uh
dare you to love me and break of a
heartache i am like is avril okay
i'm actually more than okay i'm having
the time of my life i love this record
because it has tons of energy
and like i just didn't hold back i just
went for it and like
it's like a rock and roll record all the
way through which i feel like most of my
albums are kind of just like it's like a
musical journey and this one just has
like attitude and sass all the way
through and yeah i tapped i had a lot of
time in the pandemic to kind of reflect
on my life in love and the ups and downs
i've been through and i kind of just
like
wrote songs like bite me it's like it's
like a good a goodbye um and it's like
to a guy who wants a second chance but
he doesn't deserve it and it's really
like the message throughout the album is
strong it's strong and it's empowering
and it's uplifting and it's like you
know life's short and if someone's not
treating you right then you know know
what you deserve and move forward and
and then it's their loss
listen you are not the first first
artist to turn you know great heartbreak
into great art but i'm wondering at some
point did you ever find yourself maybe
gravitating towards a situation that
maybe wasn't the best just because you
knew what could come out of it
maybe stayed a little too long
um
i mean
i don't know like i you know i've been
i've been lucky to experience some great
loves in my life and you know
sometimes
i don't know maybe it's like a season
thing this person is around for this
long whatever i've also like
you know
uh
i'm i'm at that point i was just like at
that point where i was like i need a
break but at the same time like
literally two days later like i started
dating somebody i had a new boyfriend
and like i'm like one of those people
who's like i'm like
a relationship girl like i'm i like to
be in a relationship i do love love
and um i was just feeling that way but
like my song the album is called love
sucks but the song that i wrote
also called love sucks literally the
lyric in the in the chorus it's like oh
not another breakup like nah nah not
another breakup and then it's funny it's
like when i think of you i just want to
throw up because that's like so true
so you know
so i know i i totally do i'm wondering
especially with working especially with
working with travis because you've had a
relationship with travis for a long time
and what i got from this and i'm
wondering if this was part of the
mandate is
when i hit play on your record there was
a sense of it sort of felt like home a
little bit because it was an aval record
that was 100 an avril record and i'm
wondering if that was sort of the
mandate with you and travis in the
studio to make it sound like an avril
record
well you know what i just like made this
record it was like very natural how i
fell into making an at this album i
didn't have a label i didn't have
managers and i was talking to travis
barker and he was like yo what are you
doing are you writing like let's get in
the studio and then like it like a week
later you know i'm like i was like
i had been talking to mgk about like
working on a song together like we were
like trying to figure that out and then
i went in the studio with like mod son
like a week later and all these people
were just kind of and he introduced me
to john feldman all these people were
just coming into my life at the same
time
and it was just like okay i'm making a
record like i'm always writing
but like it all just and then
all these people that i
collaborated with these musicians
it was so easy and effortless and i
really felt they all really just got me
and i didn't have to like explain like
okay the guitar like this the track like
this the direction like this we all i
went in and i was just like let's
they all knew who i was and they just
really feel like we're all the same kind
of come from like the same musical
backgrounds
so it just shaped up to they we all
really complimented each other
and so when i said like you know i want
to rock out i want to make a pop punk
record i want to make an alternative
album everyone was just like all right
let's go and it was so easy effortless
and just came together nicely with uh
with with travis barker and mgk since
the process of this happened they are
now the two most popular musicians and
fiances on planet earth right now are
you exhausted from are you exhausted
from buying your friends engagement
presents
it's it's lovely actually i'm so happy
for them they they're also perfect for
each other and
yeah
when you when you do sort of when you're
in that world and you're you're in the
studio and you're trying to work on uh
on new stuff when you start thinking of
names of people that you want to bring
in
how much does the relationship
matter when it comes to collaborating
with somebody like will you work with
somebody who's extremely talented but
maybe you don't get along with
um
no
no
unless like in the past like if the
label was like forcing me to work with
somebody which has definitely happened
but
i'm at that point where i think
i'm working now with like a record
company that like they want they respect
me and they're like you've been doing
this for a long time and they're just
like they're here to like support me and
uh like travis is the president of my
record label like he's not gonna force
me to do anything like he he gives me
his opinion
like i should i should listen because
he's usually right
and you you are going on the road and
modsun's going on the road with you um
we know you're great together we know
that you can hang out together
all that other stuff can you tour
together because have you you know i
mean that's a different beast being on
the road with somebody
he actually went on tour last fall and i
joined him and we had a song called
flames
together and uh yeah i joined him for a
few dates it was super fun and just
jumped up on stage and we'd sing mad and
i was there actually just like
supporting him while he was on his tour
that's awesome
you